here's Sunny hustin explaining that her
family doesn't like her there a scond
doll in the hus household I ordered an
artificial gold tree this year oo and
it's fabulous how trumpish I was just
going to say palom is like yay and
Gabriel was like that is not good for
the environment and I said yes it is
it's better for the environment and he's
like it's horrible and then my husband
was like what is that and so everybody's
turned against me in my house just
because I'm trying to be echo-friendly
and then I just read Echo and then I you
read the about the tree that you just
bought don't want to put me your dog G
Gabriel was right real trees help fight
climate change nobody likes you lady uh
she's also trying to be echo-friendly I
think she means eco-friendly unless
she's being friendly in a cave ech e
that's an echo echo echo echo Eco
[Music]
ecological wouldn't you like to know
weather boy